hello everyone we have a very cool
sponsor today so this one is by
squarespace Khan thank you for
sponsoring this video because there's so
many people that want to get websites
made and they don't know where to start
Squarespace com you can get it made
through a template and you don't have to
go through the traditional means of
getting a custom coding and all that
crap which is in cost a crap ton of
money yeah and if you're trying to start
a business if you don't have a website
in today's time you're gonna fail and
it's easy now because they have all
kinds of templates and for 2018 they
have eight brand new templates where you
can customize and make your website look
like it was completely custom
what's also dumped about Squarespace is
that they have award-winning 24/7
customer service it's never been easier
to sell products online now so if you
want an online store Squarespace comm is
the place to be make sure you go to
Squarespace comm for a free trial and
make sure you go to Squarespace comm
slash just kidding News for 10% off of
your first website 10% that's a day you
see you guys next time
[Music]
and [ __ ] be crazy news submitted by
bris Torres media Oh a woman shares her
story of the time a stripper bit her
finger off what thick cut on my finger I
don't know and then talking about finger
Oh like right now you're bleeding no
it's just a piece of my memories yeah
this takes place in Kansas City and I
heard it's [ __ ] like gallows Hill
over there in Kansas City I suppose be
nicer it's nicer which one Missouri
I've been to Kansas City really is it
ghetto
I know I don't remember it very worse
than from Kansas they have very thick
accents there because she tried to hide
it as best as she could until I got her
drunk and then it came out what kind of
a high y'all like that yeah so she was
like she speaks like straight up because
she should watch like Lionsgate right so
she's like very posh err city with
another city mm-hmm it's called Kansas
City on one side and the other one is
loser Kansas City like Missouri yeah
yeah yeah there's some weird [ __ ] to cuz
they do like some stuff that I couldn't
relate to because she was like oh my god
you should come out to Kansas and come
out and do a bonfire and I was like what
is that she goes you've never done a
bonfire I'm like [ __ ] it was barn fire
Oh barn yeah I was like [ __ ] the barn
fire like how am I supposed to know that
she looked at everybody does it mean we
said people's barns on fire I don't know
she explained us she was so drunk music
well we do random acts of vandalism you
know so you haven't gone Cal tip and yet
she literally said that and I was like
no we don't do these things that's what
they do over there over here we do we do
mailbox hitting in the left [ __ ] what's
what's cow tipping they typically you
just throw the cow over like you make it
fall right how do they get back faster
than it is is it funny to watch them get
back up oh okay so why do they do it
with the drop they die I'm from Kansas
so I don't don't talk about cow tipping
if you don't know about so when I was a
kid we used to I was in high school
whatever my buddy was so bad with women
that when he struck out with them we
would fork their house have you heard of
house performing no what is that
so we would go to Costco we would get
like this 500 box of plastic forks and
then you stick them handle like first in
the lawn so the forks coming up out of
the line and you pepper the whole [ __ ]
with it and so further he spends it all
his money and all his [ __ ] time to do
that hundred forks when the girl
rejected me and they always did we would
go and fork their house afterwards look
at what dissipate course there's
hilarious it was hilarious a lot of work
I did he was oh but I'm always down for
the troll my friend what was great about
this was that it was sort of a troll on
him because he didn't know that was a
reason why he's not getting [ __ ] well
they don't know that it's him
so it's his own like in a revenge thing
and so I loved his fingerprints like on
the line oh they don't do fingerprint
but ain't no cops coming to that to that
house to chase her love keeping and I
every time I walk by a house and I saw
toilet paper hanging from the tree I
thought it was the funniest thing on
earth like it will always be a riot for
me like you would never get old we've
been [ __ ] simple-minded buffoons
every time I walk by I'm like oh my god
they got TPD and then it's so
humiliating
now Duke isn't so annoying
David [ __ ] like an elementary school was
ding-dong-ditch like to hide in the bush
and watch the reaction of the person
opening up the door and they're like no
one's here that's how you know you grew
up in a neighborhood one in my hood we
didn't have trees so I don't know what
tp'ing is all about - we didn't have a
[ __ ] doorbell because it was always
[ __ ] fenced off or if he did have
adorable we knock on a door broken three
who didn't have families for we did not
pay checks oh it was apartment complex
mm-hmm oh that sucks drill yeah well
this one is the canvas city in Missouri
and Karen she was just telling her story
yes and what happened because of her
finger her ring finger the tip of it got
bitten off by stream what the flow she
doesn't really explain she had AIDS
should explain oh so like she like the
this is her explanation is the fact that
she was by the bathroom this stripper
named diamond which
the finger biter no like that's what she
oh like a stripper name is one of her
name was diamond and she's like call me
please call me Linda her stripper name
is Linda because her real name is exotic
habit I like the diamond she got into
this fight with other women but then
Karen was was by her dressing room cuz
she was waiting for the bathroom and so
somehow in that scuffle her arm got into
the fight and as she was trying to
retrieve her arm bag I got bit that's
when she bit her finger the stripper no
no I don't have photos where's her
regular face without that ridiculous
filter okay warning I'm chill oh where
did the finger go though you know what's
in scene a bloody dick on the show I'm
good really
yeah we did an article work I got a dick
fit off or some [ __ ] or guy's dick sawed
off or something yeah or you lost it on
sensitize we all know at this point we
see a lot of decapitated things earlier
we saw the capitate oh yeah it's like
her entire know that yeah she did say
that there was no bone exposed so it
didn't go all the way down so then could
we attach that [ __ ] no they couldn't
by the time so like she immediately was
rushed across the street from the strip
club to the fire station and awesome
story did city zoning manager did an ace
job yeah what a cleverly planned town
then she got to the fire department and
some of her friends went back to the
strip club to find her finger hurt her I
don't see it is that it no as dope cuz
there's no girls those are some good
friends yeah yeah ultimately for nothing
though
I will say yeah cuz they could have
reattach it and then here's a clip of
her friends but her friend took of her
so that's kind of funny is that a ring
finger yeah she crying cuz I have a
[ __ ] [ __ ] fingers Missy I know
somebody who flew off a motorcycle and
now he his ring finger is also gone cuz
they got [ __ ] scraped off that almost
happened to me here yeah that guy's
scars that's just [ __ ] crazy did
motorcycling are you gonna tell us you
gonna do it no you guys know I fell off
of a motorcycle but it wasn't even a
cool motorcycle it was like a little
pocket bike has anybody ridden on a
motorcycle not have a radical accident
me really I save life yeah thanks a lot
will you the driver
oh you wrote once you didn't own one
okay that's what I want a motorcycle
yeah really
I want one but not to be responsible not
here now we should get it in somewhere
that's very very low population like
Montana or something because I don't
know anyone that owns a motorcycle or
has ridden one that didn't drop their
motorcycle least once yes like I say
like aside from the fact that I look
really ridiculous on one like the other
reason why is because half the people I
know that have had a motorcycle have
been in a major accident they just get
back on it yeah I mean but you're
talking about the same guy who eroded
like his finger or just scraped it all
off he also flew it off flew off it
again and broke both of his arms so it's
like hmm I'm okay and then my other
friend flew off he broke his [ __ ]
pelvis it's just too many people that I
know what these cats are like it's like
I survived a skydiving accident and I'm
going back up it's like why take the hit
learn the [ __ ] lessons we for a car
accident survivor I don't ever get back
in a car you know tip yeah you're really
blowing up my points today here's the
thing about luxury the car is not a
luxury that's first of all car's seat
belts number two airbags number three
you're in close you airbags can hurt you
bud yeah but it will kill you though
Erhard a mother
for the backs cuz I've been hit by
airbag yeah it feels like a [ __ ]
punch the chest was a percentage people
who died ever you think I would never
like the difference I think you'll be
fine you'll be fine now [ __ ] break
your nose and then go through your eyes
I think your face to be pretty [ __ ] up
and then Casey my head's like thinking
about another accident and I'll snap a
rebel and your ring finger snaps off
that it's not really there's really
count at that point we could get
motorcycles that were safer numbers yeah
just get a bunch it's Batman and me and
Nikki were driving the other day and
like you know a bunch of motorcycle guys
were going by and it was like you know
mmm we called him a bunch of names don't
worry about it yeah just have to it's
like oh you guys are so fun in the car
of a Mini Cooper you guys another one
really another one and they're all like
riding up around the side oh you guys
know and the noise is so annoying it's a
[ __ ] man it's so loud I think in
California they should make it illegal
that they can't drive in between the
lanes because like my car [ __ ] my
[ __ ] know my [ __ ] windshield I hit
twice already because they're not good
at [ __ ] ride their motorcycles Durell
bow I can't move out any more than the
freeway will allow me to and I'm saying
where I'm supposed to stay I'm not gonna
move out of my [ __ ] way for you you
can move to the side of the lane I see
if I can't see you I always do David
just a tag on your your uncool point
with a really uncool point skateboarding
should be illegal might as well be on as
I'm cool as hell there we go I move out
of the way they give me a thumbs up
thank you thank you
let's do the piece like this piece I see
these cats
I saw a motorcyclist like guy who
started merging in his lane or something
and then he's almost like we got him
tabled off and the boss okay dries up
next to him hey Kix I've seen and then
just like [ __ ] goes room well that's
what I'm saying it's like a lot of these
[ __ ] well I guess it's not everybody
I can't just group everybody one thing
but it happened twice and like it's like
they're not good at driving the [ __ ]
motorcycle so they just [ __ ] knock in
everybody's [ __ ] sideview mirrors so
he's always their fault either like
that's that's the whole thing is I don't
trust other people that's why I wouldn't
get on a motorcycle it's because I don't
trust other people yeah someone might
hit you I'm not
I'm the only good driver in the whole
world I think that if you are allowed to
go in between lanes we should be allowed
to give you us obstacles yeah yes yeah I
mean hey cool dodge it
like [ __ ] man your car yeah dude
that's me Nikki's thing knows we're
always like every time that we start to
get road rage II it's like I'm the only
[ __ ] good drivers nobody who's a good
driver I'm the only good driver and it
kind of calms us down a little bit it's
like a reality check
yeah yeah yeah cuz it's like yeah we
suck dude yeah I play I'm the terrible
driver so motorcycles beware
[Music]
[Music]